Double circle, or better said P1 as it's named in the test, is two circles flown one after the other — that is, flown in direct connection.
Entry and exit, however, are on the same axis — or simply parallel to the axis where you began.
So I start on the axis, do the first circle, the second circle, and the end of the second circle has to be flown parallel to the start of the whole manoeuvre.
Then I've exited the whole thing perfectly, and that's what it's about.
Orientation in space, setting a certain bank angle and ending that bank angle — energy management, you could say, generally speaking.
OK.
You can start the whole thing flying with the brake at the loop in the hand.
That is, you take both brakes loosely at the loop in the hand and then definitely try to pull the brakes to minimum sink.
We start the manoeuvre with both brakes pulled, also at minimum sink.
We always check first, before we initiate the turn, whether the airspace is clear.
If that's the case.
Bang.
Then we initiate the right circle.
The bank angle of the circle we can now define somewhat with the inner brake.
So if we have too little bank angle, we simply pull the inner brake slowly, with feeling, a bit more.
If we have too much bank angle — and sometimes really significantly too much — then we simply pull the outer brake.
So never simply release the inner brake, but keep the inner brake and pull the outer brake until we come back out of this bank angle.
OK, now if we're in the circle and the bank angle is right, we fly the first circle to the end.
It's mostly the case that after the first circle there's another short moment where the wing pitches up and loses a bit of bank angle.
Then you can pull another two or three centimetres again to set the bank angle better again, and then shortly before we've finished the second circle,
that is, shortly before we're on our heading,
we go back into the first circle.
Then we go with the body into neutral and then, shortly before our heading, pull the outer brake down,
so that we theoretically land back at minimum sink, the way we began.
That's of course a thing you have to train — when does the outer brake come and how quickly or how slowly does the outer brake come,
so that you exit perfectly on axis with as little pendulum at the end as possible.
The same you can fly with half wrap.
There you just have to be careful, on the outside, to really stretch the hand all the way up, and at the start of course you don't have to pull the brakes down so far.
That is, brake a bit for minimum sink, then proceed exactly the same way: left up, weight right in, set the bank angle, define it,
then shortly before we're on our heading, on the second circle, bang, neutral sitting position, outer hand down,
so that we ideally come out
braked on both sides out of the whole thing.
And only after that, bang, can we transition back into gliding flight.
For the double circle a prescribed flight axis is taken up.
Through measured pulling of the right brake line two right-turning circles are flown without interruption within a maximum of 20 seconds.
By slowing the rotation early, the manoeuvre is exited on the original flight axis.
Through measured braking the heading is handed back over into gliding flight.
Through measured braking, subsequent roll and pitch movements are caught and the wing is stabilised.
Time measurement only stops once the wing flies stably on the original flight axis.